any normal person would have probably
been like I'm so sorry please throw that
out
hi my name is Jonathan David Manor I
worked at Subway for six months and
these are my horror stories it's my
personal favorite story I love this
story so some normal evening as usual
you know everything's done I'm almost
out of the door we get done closing them
I'm sweeping you know patio sweeping and
wiping down all the tables like I'm
supposed to do it so beautiful night
looks like I'm gonna get home early
folks I go outside and I'm changing the
trash right and then it's this lady she
comes you know she got like half a mouth
of teeth and then she comes up and she
got to like this really rat boys she's
like hey hey let me let me get enough
let me get it done I'm like like man I'm
like no like what are you doing she's
like I left my stuff in there let me let
me get in the trash never get in the
trash nothing ma'am what I told her was
whatever is in there it's not in there
normal but what I really wanted to tell
her was get you get what I wanted to
tell her and I'm like ma'am I'm sorry
but you have to leave and she was like
oh oh no you trying to try me you're
trying to try me and I'm like ma'am no
I'm not I'm not trying to strike Blair
maybe you just have to leave we're about
to close and she's like no I'm not you
know you know what I got for you you
know what I think of this place
she had denim shorts on I kid you not
she had denim shorts on and she had no
drawers on bro
she literally hiked the denim shorts up
last bro I got denim on right now you
can't even pull this man like it was it
was just so bad like she hiked the dumb
trucks apply ass and made a thong into
her and I just seen these big-ass brown
ash teachers just fall out the damn
chores and she's like you know what I
think you just starts want I'm bombing
her ass on all the tables that I just
got done wiping she just went oh you
like that no you know you like that well
all the goddamn table so I'm just like
I'm man man you really gonna have to
leave now I'm a Carter police you don't
say I'm gonna call LAPD and then she was
like oh I don't care about 12 and she
threw a set up and she was like come on
let's go let's go and I was all right
all right I'm a kid too you want some
and then she was like yeah let's go and
I was all right so I ran inside not a
lot of doing I called the cops
that's what I did and she got mad she
start you know banging on the window
spitting on and stuff
hey man you know what is what it is like
I'm nothing to go out there find oh man
I mean a woman sorry hi my name is Nick
thir I worked at Subway for a whopping
week and this is why so typical day at
Subway as far as I knew for being there
for a week you'd come in set everything
up get behind a cash register make sure
that's all good making a sandwich was
pretty cut and dry no pun intended
you'd literally set up the bread get
their order it's very clean I would say
behind the sneeze bar you see where I'm
going with this the hora de which I
can't believe you're making me relive
this a woman came in ordered
I remember what kind of stuff it was but
it was a sub obviously subway I take out
the bread I cut it at a attempt at
45-degree angle begin layering what she
wanted she's very persistent in a hurry
wanting to get me going she's also a
little pushy and a little in my face we
get to the veggie portion which is
almost near the end I've already got my
meat my cheese's all that all the
goodies we start doing the veggies and
she's very this woman's getting
uncomfortably close she's grabbing the
guard to kind of like point out what she
wants and I'm like all right I've seen
this before
she's a little nosy doesn't know
personal space I let it go she starts
scooting closer I'm like put your
glasses on or something lady this is
getting uncomfortable you are honestly
like like real close like it was bad I
think maybe a little bit of salt or
pepper was in the air I don't know
she uh she sneezes on me I don't know if
you guys remember this the fans that you
had the water bottle or as like a spray
mist I felt like I was at a water park
but because she was hovering over the
glass so far it was also all over her
sandwich any normal person would have
probably been like I'm so sorry
please throw that out no not even a win
streak continues picking out her order
as I'm about to throw up on myself I did
what any good subway employee would do
and I finished making the sandwich that
was my last day hi my name is Mason luck
I worked at Subway for two months and
this is my horror story so I started
working at Subway when I was 18 years
old was my first job and I was finally
gonna be making some of my own money and
having cost my parents I was working
weekends first at Subway which was fine
because it was the start of the day you
know you usually get your normal
customers but since I had to do classes
I also decided after school I would take
on some night shifts that was a terrible
idea so I go into my first night shift
it's around closing time and my coworker
who had been working at the subway for
five years she was getting her keys she
was about to lock the door and before
she could even get to the door two men
walk in my coworker tells me we actually
can't have you in right now because
we're trying to lock up and we've
already got you know food packed away
we're gonna be going home and so the
guys are like no no no like please like
let us just order a sandwich we'll like
do it really quick well like pay for and
be out of your hair in no time now mind
you I was already a little skeptical
because these guys were huge guys not
trying to prejudge but I already was
feeling uneasy and so we finished making
their sandwiches they pay we put
everything in a to-go bag so they can
head out and instead of leaving like
they had said they would they sit at a
table right across from the register and
unwrap their food and start eating me
and my coworker are looking at each
other and we're just kind of like why
aren't these guys leaving like what are
we supposed to do and she had more
experience I expected that she would be
the first to kind of jump in and tell
the guys I need to go but instead she
looked at me and she goes okay you need
to go tell those guys that they need to
leave I'm like five foot one at the time
I weigh like a buck maybe like a buck
two and I'm like you want me to tell
these guys who are towering over me that
they need to leave so I'm like okay you
know what's the worst that could happen
it got worse I go over to their table
and I'm like hey like I'm really sorry I
hate to be the one to tell you but I'm
really gonna have to ask you guys to
lean
they looked at me like as if I had just
punched their grandma and they just
started yelling and getting very loud
and they're like how are you gonna tell
us to leave what are you gonna make us
leave like you can't do anything to us
we're gonna stay here and we're gonna
finish eating our food and you're gonna
stay here until we're done and at that
point I was like okay this could get
very violent very fast so I go back over
to my coworker and she hears the whole
commotion and I tell her like well what
should we do like should we call the
manager and so she's like well I don't
want to bother the manager with this I
will call the police and then she's like
go tell them that we're gonna call the
police
so me being naive I was just like okay
I'm gonna go tell them and then they're
gonna feel threatened and run out the
door
they weren't threatened at all and in
fact it made them even more upset they
continued to yell at me and tell me like
if you're gonna call the police you know
you're gonna have another problem I run
back to my coworker who's now in the
kitchen completely avoiding this whole
confrontation and leaving me to deal
with it so I go to my coworker like hey
so what did the police say like how long
are they how long is it gonna take them
to get here and she goes oh I didn't
call the police and I'm just sitting
there like okay I guess we're gonna get
murdered in a subway tonight like this
is how I die so we're in the back just
wondering when these guys are gonna
leave and we're at this point we're
thinking we're gonna end up spending the
night here I think like 20 or 30 minutes
past finally like I hear from the front
the door open and it was just like such
a relief to just know that they were
finally leaving and I was so upset with
the whole situation and I was young and
I was just like I don't have to deal
with this like I could just keep asking
my parents for money again literally the
next day I call it I was like I'm not
coming back here I'm never coming back
I'm never making another sandwich and to
this day every time a friend is just
like yeah let's go get Subway let's go
eat at Subway and I walk in that door
just the smell of that bread baking and
just everything in there just like
haunts me to this day
which is so sad because all I ever
wanted was a sandwich
instead I get trauma
[Music]